[Applause]
pink y'all hello da fest my name is
Melissa and I'm a web developer from
Serbia right now I'm working with Google
on writing about performance and
developer tools so things like web pack
and lighthouse I'm be digital on Twitter
and you can also find me on different
corners of the internet like tumblr
medium powerlifting reddit I actually
learned HTML and CSS by tweaking myspace
I got interested in performance last
year when I was interning at Mozilla I
worked on a browser engine called servo
which makes browsing fast by making
better use of modern hardware it can do
that because it was written in rust rust
is a new systems programming language
that's kind of like C but cool so I got
a little bit of rust last year and I
liked it but I also loved the web and I
didn't want to move to native
development I want to talk to you today
about how you can run native code on the
web why would you want to do that and
what does it all mean for the future of
web development this would be a gentle
intro to webassembly what it is how it
works and how it can benefit from it
even if you continue to write jeaious
only there will be some cool examples
some weird ones and some practicals one
practical ones too so let's get started
in every browser whether you use Chrome
Firefox edge or Safari code is
interpreted and executed by a JavaScript
engine which only runs JavaScript
unfortunately javascript is not ideal
for every task that we want to perform
that's where web assembly steps in web
assembly is the new type of code that
can be run in modern browsers it is
created to get better performance on the
web it's a low-level binary format it's
small if it has a small size so it's
fast to load and fast to execute
you do not write webassembly you compile
other higher-level languages to it just
over all in the same page assembly
typically refers to human readable
languages that are similar to machine
code machine code is what your processor
understands a bunch of numbers every
higher level programming language needs
to get translated down to machine code
in order to run on the processor
different kinds of processor
architectures need different machine
codes and different kind of assembly for
each of them even though it's called web
assembly it's not quite an assembly
language because it's not meant for any
specific machine it's for the browsers
and when you're delivering code to be
executed in the browser you don't know
what kind of machines will your code be
running on so web assembly is the
language for a conceptual machine that's
the least common denominator of popular
real-world hardware when the browser
downloads the web assembly binary it can
quickly turn it into any machines
assembly this is what sub assembly looks
like it has a textual format dot wet
that you can easily read but binary
format is what you actually deliver to
the browser dot wasum what what assembly
enables you to do is take things like C
C++ or rest code and compile it into
what's called a web assembly module you
can load that module into your
application and call it from JavaScript
web assembly is not a replacement for
JavaScript it works alongside JavaScript
so now that you know what it is let's
talk about why do we need web assembly
the short answer is performance think
about cases we want to where you need to
use software outside of the browser
things like video games
3d rendering music production these
applications require a high degree of
performance and that kind of performance
is hard to get from JavaScript
JavaScript started as a simple scripting
language meant to bring some
interactivity to the web full of
lightweight hypertext documents this is
the first website ever made by Tim
berners-lee so it's just like bunch of
text with some links at that time
javascript was designed to be easy to
learn and easy to write it wasn't
designed to be fast over the years
browser size optimizations in the way
they interpret JavaScript has brought
major performance improvements as it got
faster the list of things that you could
do with the browser started expanding we
got new api's things like interactive
graphics video streaming of wine
browsing and many more more and more
rich applications started coming to the
web applications that were previously
desktop only so today you can easily
edit documents and send email from your
browser but there are still areas where
JavaScript performance is a struggle
video games are especially challenging
because they have to coordinate not only
audio and video but also physics and
artificial intelligence being able to
reach the level of performance to run
games on the web efficiently with the
open the doors to bringing many other
applications to the web and that's what
webassembly is set out to do it's a good
fit not only for video games but also
CAD applications virtual and augmented
reality audio and video codecs VPN
encryption remote desktop the list goes
on you can see it's on the official
wobbly website
but why would we want to do all this
stuff on the web why is the web so
attractive to me the beauty of the web
is this is kind of like magic it works
anywhere
there's no download and no installation
browsers have security properties they
keep code running in them from messing
with your system does the thing called
sandbox and my favorite sharing on the
web is as easy as it gets
links are just clickable strings that
you can put anywhere and we all know
that's not how app stores work so the
web is the only truly universal platform
it makes your code accessible on any
device for us developers that means you
can maintain a single code base and it
makes updates simple because of all this
and the interactivity that the web
offers we went from hypertext and a
simple scripting language all the way to
an incredibly powerful and popular
platform filled with amazing
applications but until now it was still
fundamentally powered by the same
scripting language that wasn't designed
to do all this in the first place so
what does web assembly bring to the
table there are three main things speed
Portability and flexibility let's talk a
bit about speed web assembly was
designed for speed its binaries are much
smaller than textual JavaScript files
because of their size they are faster to
download and this is a special
importance for networks browsers all are
also working on streaming compilation
aka compiling during download so for
small wineries like this this basically
means that by the time code is
downloaded it's already compiled there
are also faster to decode and execute
JavaScript is a dynamically typed
language
variable types don't have to be defined
up front and it doesn't need to be
compiled ahead this makes it easy and
fast to write but it also means that
javascript engine has a lot more work to
do it has to compile parse and optimize
the code as it's being executed on the
page parsing JavaScript involves
transforming plain text into structure
called Apps abstract syntax tree and
turning that into binary format web
assembly is delivered as binary so
decoding it happens much faster it's
statically typed so unlike with
JavaScript the engine doesn't need to
speculate during compilation about which
types are going to be used most of the
optimization with valve assembly happens
during the computations from the source
code before it even gets into the
browser memory is managed manually just
like in a languages like C and C++ so
there's no garbage collection either
this is a relative time spent processing
javascript and web assembly in the
engine all this gives better and more
reliable performance the execution time
of JavaScript binaries is just 20%
slower than the execution of the same
native code
sorry all okay let's talk about
portability of it this was one of the
main goals when designing web assembly
to run an application on a device it has
to be compatible with devices processor
architecture and operating system this
means compiling the source code for
every combination of operating system
and CPU architecture that you want
support with web assembly there's only
one compilation step and your app will
run in every modern browser good use
case is porting legacy applications and
open source libraries to the web there
is a huge amount of C++ libraries and
open source applications out there and
now with web assembly you can make it
all available on the web in C++
specifically is languages supported on
practically every platform including iOS
and Android which means you could use it
as a common language for both your web
and mobile deployments another exciting
thing is about web assembly is that it
brings flexibility in writing for the
web until now
javascript has been the only fully
supported language with fab assembly web
developers will be able to choose
different languages for writing for the
web and also more developers will be
able to write code for the web
javascript will still be the best choice
for most use cases but now you will have
an option to drop down to specialized
language once in a while when you really
need to boost and also parts like UI and
the applaud ik can be written in
JavaScript well a specific core
functionality can be written in web
assembly if you have an existing app
that's struggling with performance you
will be able to optimize those
bottlenecks in a language that's better
suited suited for the problem right now
fully supported languages are C C++ and
rust but many
are in the works dotnet and Kotlin
already shipped experimental support in
there and the list goes on this has a
lot to do with the features that are
still coming to webassembly and they
will make it a more suitable target for
many other languages now that you know
what it is let's talk a bit about how
does it work I said there will be
dragons in my talk and this is it this
is the logo of LLVM a modular compiler
tool chain that you can use with many
different languages you can output
webassembly with it
a simple simpler tool is called M
scripting and it's based on LLVM you can
use this one for C and C++ rust
Knightley has its own compiler called
rust see that can output webassembly
directly so if you have a hello world
written in C this is the command that
will give you a web assembly binary MCC
is in scripting command then we have
hello C which is our source file - as
well as equals 1000 scripting that we
wanted to talk with web assembly and
that show hello dot HTML specifies our
output file what you get is the web
assembly binary along with JavaScript
and HTML files this might look weird but
you actually need HTML and j/s because
valve assembly doesn't have direct
access to any platform api's that means
the Dom WebGL web audio or anything to
work with these and even to display the
output of web assembly on your web page
you have to go through JavaScript so in
scripting creates the glue code that
sets up your web assembly module and
makes communicating with web api is
possible then the HTML file loads that
and displays the out
of your webassembly code in a text area
or a canvas now you can think of other
sembly binaries as regular app modules
browsers can fetch download and execute
them they have imports in app exports
that allow you to work with them the
same way you work with JavaScript
objects you can call web assembly
functions in JavaScript code and you can
call JavaScript functions in webassembly
modules now it's not all that great it
has only four primitive types in there
own numbers integers and floats
this means that passing more complex
data types before between javascript and
web assembly is not quite simple if you
want to pass a string for example like
hello world
you have to encode it into an array of
numbers and then pass a pointer to it it
has no direct access to external JS
variables so it can only read and write
from its own linear memory in order to
access J's fireballs you have to either
copy them into memory or pass them
through calls back right now making a
lot of calls between Jas and webassembly
is not very fast that's because the
engine has to do a lot of startup work
each time firefox did a great job
recently and made these calls i think
maybe like 100 times faster but other
browsers still have work to do so right
now you should think of web assembly as
a system the Transvaal in isolation you
can often use it to offload the big
chunks of work
you're probably wondering now whether
you can use this in production today and
the answer is yes webassembly supports
rolled out last year and it's currently
supported in all major browsers it's
supported for 80% of global users and
even 86% of users on desktop as a
fallback for other browsers you can use
a thing called Azzam j/s there can be
also outputted from its own scripting as
there is a subset of JavaScript that
works only with numbers so that means no
strings no objects or anything it was a
format that directly led to creation of
web assembly if you ever tried to upload
a huge photo to Facebook you went
through web assembly probably Facebook
is using this old C library called Lib
JPEG for image compression in these
cases I think Lib JPEG is almost 40
years old and they were actually
compiling it to as entrails before but
right now if you have a modern browser
you're getting web assembly here and
also if you've ever played audio or
video file on Wikipedia they are also
using open source codecs that are
compiled to vamp assembly and as entrer
asked for that it's time for some
examples
I mentioned video games as a big goal
for web assembly and both unity and
unreal engine 4 already have working
demos you can play a game of tanks in
the browser I'm going to try to show
this to you right now but it might not
okay I don't think my laptop can handle
this but I can show you a video of zen
garden from hmm ok maybe not quite yet
there is also a demo from Unreal Engine
called the Zen garden and it's a
Japanese garden with the whole lot
interactive elements falling leaves
fluttering butterflies blossoming
cherries things that are very
computationally intensive and they're
running inside the browser with
webassembly right now they're also other
interesting demos online like a video
editor raytracer facial recognition
algorithm so this is ray tracing that's
a technique that
madellaine can probably tell you a bit
more about and here we have video editor
right here in the browser that doing
applying filters in real time this is
very computationally intensive
shape and you could do this with
JavaScript before but with webassembly
the performance is many times fast
faster and it works very very smoothly
there are some cool filters just
probably check it out on your own later
people are also doing weird things with
this someone ported Windows 2000 and now
we have an operating system in the
browser you can actually go to this link
I'll leave it after my talk and you can
load windows play minesweeper maybe
someone is fan of pinball yeah pinball
is a great one right
there are also big apps out there using
webassembly figma is an interface design
tool the trends in the browser and
allows designers to easily collaborate
on their work it was mostly written in
C++ and it has two DVI l rendering
engine that can handle very large
documents the UI and app logic are
actually written in typescript and react
initially they were using smj s for
compiling C++ to the web and once they
switch to webassembly their load time
improved by three times regardless of
the document size another great example
is AutoCAD software which is used mostly
in engineering fields for things like
floor plans piping designs electrical
circuits it's written in C++
it has been around for 35 years and last
year with web assembly they were able to
port this huge code base to the web
without needing to rewrite anything so
now you can actually use professional
CAD software in the browser so this
focus on waiting obviously works but is
going to get even better let's see what
lies ahead
the browser browsers are already working
on new features support for threading
and garbage collection is coming
this will make a web assembly more
suitable target for languages like Java
C sharp and go another important goal
for web assembly is creating debugging
tools that were supported with support
showing source code for the web assembly
modules but even if you continue to work
with JavaScript only you can still
benefit from web assembly and the speed
boost that it brings
through improved libraries and
frameworks soon enough you'll be able to
download and import these modules like
any other ACMA script module with script
tag type module and you can simply call
those functions from JavaScript web
assembly modules are already in the NPM
registry and it's possible that in the
future you'll be able to easily use open
source software written in any language
right from the NPM and as for the
frameworks view j/s is actually already
investigating implementation of their
glimmr engine in webassembly and also
there's potential for react to implement
some of their core features in web
assembly things like different algorithm
that could be much faster if it was
written in another language now
javascript will still have its place in
web development it's a great language
flexible enough to build almost anything
those few gaps that it cannot fill can
now be filled with web assembly so this
is not the end of javascript I think
it's a new beginning for the web if you
want to learn more about this topic how
web assembly works what are new features
that are coming you should check out
code code tunes by link Clark who is my
mentor at Mozilla and I won't be putting
my slides online but if you want to read
through this at your own pace you should
check out the blog post I published on
meeting thanks for having me and thanks
to Ed about everyone from organization
who did a great job with this conference
you